if Shopify decided they were gonna have
ten retail locations in ten cities it's
a crazy thought of course what would you
do in those 10 locations would you just
allow people to rent them by the day to
do special events I mean what is it that
exists yeah I mean that's I have nothing
prepared for this but I think it would
be cool idea like the thing is like we
need like the year-long lease is clearly
not right so that needs to be disrupted
somehow so you know one easy way to do
it is larger entities taking a lot of
space and giving giving out four terms
to other people so like kind of
industrializing in a way the the pop-up
shop concept compressing opthamology
done that it's such a great idea why we
did the pop-up Shore stores in New York
people don't know what a pop-up store is
it's a store that's open for a limited
amount of time yeah but because of the
retailer you're saying because it's
having to sign the lease it just makes
it untenable to somebody who's got a
smaller business and and I mean you
encounter all the problems that and you
bow or someone would like you you have
to think this is a company but just best
started by a heck of a crazy disregard
for for status quo and a lawyer because
you really like you're gonna fight by
laws everywhere like most studies most
cities don't allow businesses like to
sign like to come in anywhere before
under like a month for yeah a quarter so
so this is one of those businesses which
is just really messy if you want to do
yeah you get into into it so I don't
honestly know maybe maybe this is the
future of Best Buy again like but I
think it should be done yeah I would
love for someone to do it I would love
to be able to go and be like meet the
people who created this product on the
first Monday of every month they take
over the store for you know whatever 18
hours from an aid from 7:00 a.m. until
11 p.m.
they're gonna do an experience just for
this company that makes beautiful cases
and you meet the CEO and you meet the
product manager and they go through what
they thought of and they show you the
the five new man bags and Merces and
satchels and and this is I mean it's
such a good point because
I mean why's Kickstarter successful
intimate personal innovative the
experience I don't even like it I don't
think that the kicks have success has
anything to do with crowdfunding it's
it's a completely miss miss attribution
of a success the reason why the kicks
are successful because if false the
actual person who comes up with a
product and they could be about it
right that's completely accidental and
everyone forgets about this but if the
people who create the products but
people would know more than anyone else
no word about something tell you not
just what the product does and all the
kind of platitudes that the marketing
history has focused on for last hundred
years but rather the reason of why they
event there why they're built this why
this is a product I needed to come into
existence you have a much much more
powerful thing and that is a problem
that Best Buy brings like the problem is
when you have someone like Best Buy
they will not tell you the story and the
channel between the people will create
the things the creators for curators the
craftspeople these that there's a layer
between them and for consumers it's just
simply a construct of history that is
related to how the solution was owned
previously and if it can be shattered
it was extremely powerful because like
you I would like then when I go to buy
something I would like the person who
came up with this to explain to me why
this virus is useful and I think there's
a way to build an infrastructure to make
this happen and disintermediate like
this world process and make it a lot
more interesting like if you have
products
if you have products that have barcodes
Amazon is going to be the best mover to
sell these things and there's nothing
you can do like Amazon is the logical
and conclusion of this branch of retail
that is a department store right and no
department store will be able to survive
against them once they realize that and
actually build department stores or just
buy all the best buys or whatever yeah
so that's going to happen which is
what's left the left other products that
don't have barcodes for things bad again
owned by creators and curators and
people who add a lot of value to these
things lie against the snowboards of
used to sell some commodity of product
exactly
but it's the interesting stuff it's a
stuff that we want you know like the
stuff we need like deodorant or coffee
beans or yeah whatever but we really
desire the satchel that's may hand
crafted or the iPhone case that's got
the three extra features that are really
well thought out
yeah oh if you but if you buy a guitar
like the guitar industry is really
really great like this this is like very
small business usually 50 people per
company somewhere in the United States
selling these things you know to guitar
store on Guitar Center but also
throughout their own websites and they
tell their own stories may do a really
great job it's a much much better
experience if you can to of those
factories that's that's really what we
need again like this sort of you know
intimate relationship with the things
artisanal is like the movement in food
right absolutely
small small packets and something that